elizabeth holmes aspired to be steve
jobs but it turns out that she's more
like bernie madoff in 2003 a 19 year old
college dropout named elizabeth holmes
founded a company called theranose that
promised to revolutionize blood testing
she claimed to have invented a machine
that could run more than 200 tests on
just a few drops of blood taken from a
finger prick she wanted to sell
diagnostic tests directly to consumers
holmes was very persuasive she gave a
ted talk where she promoted their notes
by calling it the most disruptive
technology in the history of medicine
yet in the united states today
health care
is the leading cause of bankruptcy
and the lack of it
the leading cause of the suffering
associated with finding out
too late
in the disease progression process
that someone you love
is really really sick silicon valley
investors treated her like a rock star
walgreens quickly became a corporate
partner major investors included rupert
murdoch the walton family and the family
of former education secretary betsy
devos holmes's big promises attracted
some of the biggest names in american
government in foreign policy bill
clinton was charmed by her and joe biden
praised her efforts secretaries of state
henry kissinger and george schultz
joined the board of directors former
secretaries of defense james mattis and
william perry joined too the company
raised nearly one billion dollars in
funding with a prospect of eliminating
many lab tests and their associated
costs there seemed to be nothing
stopping their nose from becoming a mega
player in the biotech industry its
highest valuation was an eye-popping
nine billion dollars but walgreens
murdoch the u.s foreign policy
establishment and the other investors
ignored a very important principle in
investing and life if something seems
too good to be true it probably is too
good to be true
[Music]
as it turns out there's no way to run
hundreds of sophisticated diagnostic
tests on a few drops of blood despite
all the evidence that holmes knew her
testing machine would never work a
federal jury convicted her on just four
of the 11 charges against her three for
wire fraud against investors and one for
conspiracy to commit wire fraud against
investors one juror said it was tough to
convict her because quote she was so
likable she had such a positive dream
and it's a dream that they think she
honestly still believes in but as you
can see there's probably a reason why
jennifer lawrence katie holmes and
amanda seyfried are all practicing their
most charming and cold-blooded stares so
today we're going to talk about the
elizabeth holmes trial why did the jury
find her guilty why did they acquit her
on the other charges and how much did
holmes help herself by testifying in her
own defense so let's start with the
problems with theranos which have been
well chronicled at this point blood
analysis is one of the most important
areas of medicine the two main players
in the field quest diagnostics and
laboratory corporation of america
generate over 75 billion dollars a year
in revenue theranos promised to upend
this regime by eliminating blood draws
vials large needles and lengthy waiting
periods what if you could just go to
walgreens buy a testing kit and screen
yourself for high cholesterol kidney
disease or even cancer wouldn't that be
great you'd save time money get
diagnosed faster and lives would be
saved and that was the heart of the
theranos project but there was just one
problem with this vision most blood
tests could not be done with just a few
drops of blood there aren't enough
molecules for detection one of holm's
professors had rejected her early ideas
for biotech companies on the basis that
the science and technology could not
exist the professor phyllis gardner
later said that she found the
conversations concerning because holmes
refused to accept that some ideas were
not possible she said quote the hubris
of that just drove me insane but holmes
dropped out in 2004 and went on her own
way aggressively selling her ideas to
investors her company named their nose
is a combination of therapy and
diagnostics and while holmes never
submitted any of her inventions for any
kind of peer review that didn't matter
to another stanford professor channing
robertson he said that the minute he
heard her idea about a diagnostic test
from a pinprick he felt he was looking
into the eyes of steve jobs or bill
gates steve jobs was of course the
person that many company founders wanted
to emulate jobs created his own persona
dressing only in black and promoting
himself as an eccentric genius homes
took note of this and created her own
mythos that was trying to piggyback on
jobs she wore a black turtleneck in
black suit every day
she had a intense
stare that became famous and we might
laugh about this now but according to
tyler schultz a theranos employee
investors like his grandfather george
schultz were mesmerized by this act but
then came the whistleblowers in 2014
tyler schultz emailed holmes to complain
that their nose had doctored research
and ignored failed quality control
checks several other employees had also
raised concerns about the company's
science george schultz was 95 at the
time and holmes called him immediately
to warn him that she would get revenge
on his grandson if he took his
complaints any further tyler though
anonymously contacted new york state's
public health lab and filed a complaint
alleging that their nose had manipulated
a process known as proficiency testing
relied on by federal and state
regulators to monitor the accuracy of
lab tests their nose's lawyer david
boyes who later joined the board of
directors surprised tyler at his
grandfather's house informing him that
the company was suing him for violating
the terms of his nda and while tyler was
the first person to raise concerns about
theranos to outside regulators he
wouldn't be the last in 2015 the wall
street journal published a series of
articles exposing the theranos testing
machines as frauds by then holmes had
been appointed to the harvard medical
board alongside her old professor
phyllis gardner gardner spoke with wall
street journal about her belief that
holmes was a fraud and sure enough
regulators soon discovered that holmes's
edison machines frequently failed
quality control checks that means they
produced unreliable test results
theranos eventually told regulators that
it voided all test results from edison
machines for 2014 and 2015 as well as
some other tests it ran on conventional
machines the edison machine turned out
to be a lemon theranos claimed that its
test for one sexually transmitted
infectious disease was sensitive enough
to detect the disease 95 of the time but
when these results were submitted for
validation it showed sensitivities of
between 65 and 80 percent at the time
walgreens was partnering with theranos
to provide in-store testing centers at
40 walgreen's locations but when
walgreens realized the scope of the
problem they sued their nose for 140
million dollars walgreens eventually
claimed that theranos avoided 11.3 of
all blood test reports that the company
provided to customers of walgreens
stores but instead of acknowledging the
problems with the edison machine
theranos fabricated the results while
continuing to market the company to
investors as world-changing technology
during the trial of elizabeth holmes
prosecutors showed a presentation that
she had made to the board of directors
saying that 10 of the 15 largest
pharmaceutical companies in the world
had validated the theranost results this
was a lie the u.s centers for medicare
and medicaid services investigated their
nose and banned homes from operating a
medical lab for two years the u.s
securities and exchange commission the
sec
charged holmes and former theranost
president sunny balwani with fraud and
barred homes from serving as a director
or officer of a public company for a
decade so that brings us to the criminal
case itself holmes was indicted on 11
felony charges in 2018. the charges
included wire fraud against investors
wire fraud against patience and
conspiracy and federal prosecutors
painted holmes as a charlatan who knew
her technology didn't work they said she
was obsessed with fame and fortune and
prosecutors presented evidence that when
theranos realized his test results were
not accurate the company substituted
tests from regular blood draws making it
look as if the tests were from blood
droplet tests rather than traditional
blood draws and conventional machines
but the strongest evidence showed that
holmes exaggerated the company's
involvement with potential partners
prosecutors demonstrated that holmes
lied about having deals with drug
companies like pfizer and the us
military holmes even added the logos of
pfizer and sharing plow to lab reports
that she used in her presentation to
investors and walgreens executives but
these companies hadn't actually
validated any of their noses systems but
the defense put on a case as well holmes
testified for seven days presenting
herself as a visionary woman in a
male-dominated field holmes told the
jury that she still believed that their
nose was on the verge of proving its
technology worked she blamed her
ex-partner sonny balwani for misleading
regulators about the tests holmes told
the jury that the two had secretly lived
together and that balwani abused her
throughout the relationship and bowani
himself will go on trial later this year
and holmes attempted to raise a good
faith defense to the wire fraud charges
although good faith is a defense to wire
fraud an honest belief in the ultimate
success of the enterprise is not in
itself a defense and the judge
instructed the jury that if they
believed that she acted in good faith in
her representations then she could not
also have acted with an intent to
defraud so let's dig into the elements
of wire fraud and the conspiracy charges
that she faced
holmes was eventually convicted of three
counts of wire fraud and conspiracy to
commit wire fraud 18 usc 1343 is the
wire fraud statute it states whoever
having devised or intending to devise
any scheme or artifice to defraud or for
obtaining money or property by means of
false or fraudulent pretenses
representations or promises transmits or
causes to be transmitted by means of
wire radio or television communication
in interstate or foreign commerce any
writing signs signals yadda yadda shall
be fined under this title or in prison
not more than 20 years or both so the
prosecution had to prove four elements
first that she knowingly participated in
in some sort of scheme to defraud and
obtain money or property from other
people expressions of opinions
aspirations or goals or general
subjective claims can't be used as a
basis to find that someone made a false
or fraudulent representation this is an
important point and one we'll come back
to when we talk about the jury's
conclusion that she didn't defraud
consumers
probably because some jurors said that
she believed that she had positive goals
but the second prong is that the
statements made as part of the scheme
have to be material statements tend to
be material if they have a natural
tendency to influence or capable of
influencing a person to part with their
money the third prong is that the
government needed to show that holmes
acted with the intent to defraud that is
that she had the intent to deceive and
cheat someone out of their money or
property and then the fourth prong is
that holmes use interstate wire
communication to carry out an essential
part of this scheme and the jury found
that holmes misrepresentations
influenced investors to send money to
theranos and that her presentations
actively intended to defraud investors
by making them believe that theranos had
big government contracts and private
partnerships that would produce a high
rate of return on their investment and
the jury also found that holmes had
agreed with other people to perpetrate
this scheme on others that's why she was
convicted of a conspiracy to commit wire
fraud as well the prosecution had lots
of evidence that holmes concocted test
results to convince investors that the
science behind her test was sound in at
2014 forbes article holm said that their
nose quote does not buy any analyzers
from third parties and that was
absolutely a lie their nose presented
results conducted on these third-party
analyzers during their presentations to
investors and it's highly likely that
the jury thought that these lies were
material and that they convinced
investors to part with their money and
the three counts represented a total of
about 142 million dollars in fraud but
the jury deadlocked on three additional
wire fraud counts related to investments
from three theranos investors alan
eisenman chris lucas of black diamond
ventures and brian tolbert of the hall
group prosecutors now have to decide
whether they are going to retry her on
those three counts because the jury hung
so they couldn't come to a decision on
those particular accounts but holmes and
bolwani were also accused of conspiring
to commit wire fraud in violation of 18
usc 1349 the doj charged balwanian
holmes with making materially false and
misleading statements to investors the
government alleged that the duo quote
made materially false and misleading
statements to investors and failed to
disclose material facts this included
telling investors that the company's
proprietary analyzer was accurate when
in truth it had serious accuracy
problems
performed a limited number of tests was
slower than some competing devices and
could not compete with larger
conventional machines in high throughput
or the simultaneous testing of blood for
many patients homes in bolwani promised
investors a return on their investment
in the hundreds of millions of dollars
while knowing that the company would
only gross a few hundred thousand
dollars in 2014 and 2015. prosecutors
proved that balwanian homes faked test
results during live presentations for
investors and the doj also said that
holmes told investors that the walgreens
partnership would be expanding when in
reality walgreens was already moving to
end the partnership bolwani and holmes
told investors that their nose
technology had already been deployed by
the us military
on the battlefield in afghanistan which
was untrue general mattis testified that
they were not being used by the military
when the jurors spoke out after the
verdict two of them said that the jury
ranked witnesses according to their
believability and that they rated mattis
as the witness with the highest
credibility not surprising mattis said
that he wanted the military to do a test
program of theranos analyzers but the
test never happened while wanting it
homes told investors that they didn't
need fda approval for the machines and
tests when they already knew that they
needed clearance from the fda and the
two also allegedly lied to the media and
then use the articles and news segments
containing their lives to promote their
notes to investors and to find holmes
guilty of the conspiracy charges the
jury had to believe that she patched a
plan to commit wire fraud in partnership
with balwani or others if the jurors
thought that she just went along with
balwani because of their partnership
that probably wouldn't have risen to the
level of conspiracy but what about the
other charges of fraud for crimes
perpetrated against patients the jury
actually acquitted homes of wire fraud
and conspiracy to defraud patients so
let's talk about why that likely
happened during the four-month trial the
prosecution devoted very little time to
proving this part of the case the
patients who purchased their nose tests
only testified for about one hour in
total the government accused holmes and
theranos of making material
misrepresentations about his edison
machine in advertisements the ads mostly
targeted physicians the prosecution
argued that these ads induced hundreds
of patients to pay theranose or
walgreens for blood tests and test
results which obviously wouldn't have
worked the government said balwani and
holmes told doctors and patients that
their nose could provide accurate fast
reliable and cheap blood tests and test
results but they already knew that their
nose technology was in fact not capable
of consistently producing accurate and
reliable results
this was the alleged wire fraud because
theranost used interstate electronic
wires to purchase advertisements
intending to induce individuals to buy
the tests at
walgreens and stores in california and
arizona and the prosecution had evidence
that theranos placed advertisements in
walgreens and on tv with their total
marketing efforts slightly over 1
million dollars but at the same time the
prosecutors didn't have the same kinds
of direct communications between homes
and individual patients as they did
between homes and investors and
theoretically patients only use their
nose tests because they were referred by
their physicians so it's possible the
jury might have believed that there were
too many intermediaries between homes
and the individual patients and doctors
to conclude that homes actually
influenced the patients themselves and
the defense argued that the prosecution
needed to show that holmes really
intended to defraud these patients
arguably her company gave patients
inaccurate test results but inaccurate
test results alone don't necessarily
meet the criteria for an intent to
defraud the prosecutors needed to prove
beyond a reasonable doubt that holmes
knowingly participated in devised or
intended to devise a plan to defraud
these patients and as we talked about
earlier generally opinions aspirations
goals or subjective beliefs can be used
as a basis to find that someone made a
false or fraudulent representation and
the jurors who spoke out after the
verdict said that they believed holmes
when she said she never intended to
defraud patients and juror number six
wayne katz an emmy-winning tv writer for
a 1990s show called tiny toons
adventures was inspired by holmes's
testimony quote we respected elizabeth
belief in her technology in her dream we
thought she still believes in it and we
still believe she believes in it he's
saying that she had a subjective belief
even to this day that she was helping
her patients not hurting them cat said
that the jury quickly decided to acquit
homes on all four counts of fraud
against patients the jury thought holmes
was one step removed from the patients
so that they were not directly defrauded
of course this was also somewhat
contradictory since cats also opined
that everything ran through homes but
this is just what you often get from
jurors who are grappling with difficult
questions of law mike q juror number 11
said that although the panel thought
holmes's credibility was low they also
believed that she was genuine but what
happens next each of the four counts
that holmes was convicted of carries a
maximum sentence of 20 years in prison
so theoretically she could get 80 years
in prison but this will be reduced and
modified by the federal sentencing
guidelines several former prosecutors
think she'll probably get less than 20
years in prison especially as a
first-time offender and the high-profile
nature of the case and the scope of the
fraud probably suggests that she won't
exactly get a slap on the wrist though
that's because the federal sentencing
guidelines require the judge to consider
the magnitude of the lies and how much
money the investors lost and the fact
that she was ceo in these kinds of
white-collar crimes the more money that
is uh pilfered
the more prison you can get and 140
million dollars is quite a lot though
holmes may be able to sway the judge for
less prison time by pointing to her
relative youth her capacity for change
and the allegations of abuse at the
hands of balwani and there will almost
certainly be a very hefty fine the
government can retry her on the other
wire fraud charges but that seems
unlikely the government has already
spent significant resources and time on
the case and they got a conviction on
four counts carrying a serious prison
sentence so that may be enough
particularly in light of the upcoming
balwani trial which is also probably
going to be an expensive prosecution so
it turns out that theranose was a fraud
and a terrible investment but you can
avoid terrible investments and start
investing for your goals with today's
sponsor wealthfront wealthfront is an
automated investment platform that uses
software to find the optimal portfolio
to grow your money long term based on
your risk tolerance when you're young
you have decades of compound interest to
use to your advantage meaning that over
time your money can make you more money
which then makes you more money and that
makes you even more money and there's
decades of data out there showing that
investing in a globally diversified
portfolio of low-cost index funds is one
of the best ways to put your savings to
work and wealthfront makes that process
easy accessible and affordable no matter
what your knowledge or finances their
account setup is also incredibly simple
you just need a few minutes and 500 to
open an investment account and they will
take care of the rest they also
automatically use a strategy called tax
loss harvesting that could lower the
taxes that you pay without any
additional work on your end and best of
all they've agreed to waive their
already tiny 0.25 management fee up to
the first thousand dollars invested for
the rest of your life not to mention
they also give you free access to their
financial planning tools which allow you
to estimate your net worth over time and
estimates how you could further save and
invest more money based on your income
and spending so all you have to do to
try out wealthfront is click on the link
that's on screen right now or in the
description and again to start investing
today and get wealthfront to waive their
annual management fee up to the first
five thousand dollars for the rest of
your life click on the link that's on
screen and while you're there click on
this link for more real law reviews or
i'll see you in court